bonjour à tous on s'en souviendra de
l'année 2020 quelle année on a vécu et
si on essayait de se représenter
les 366 jours qui nous séparent du jour
de l'an 2020 alors on verrait à quel
point la réalité peut rendre pensable
l'impensable ou réelle l'impensable
cette épidémie a été évidemment terrible
pour ceux qui ont perdu un être cher il
ya plusieurs dizaines de milliers des
nôtres qui sont partis et certains à qui
je pense que nous aimions beaucoup il y
à la maladie il y à tout ce qu'ils ont
pu cette épreuve terrible de
l'hospitalisation et puis des soins
parfois lourd il y a les familles il y à
toute l'économie
toute l'économie de la planète qui a
souffert de ce qui s'est passé avec
beaucoup d'entreprises qui ont été
menacés qui sont menacés aujourd'hui et
le soutien formidable que l'état a
apporté aux entreprises et aux familles
tout ça c'est une saga la saga de 2020
que nous avons mémoire et que nous
garderons mémoire longtemps et
maintenant nous avons devant nous des
défis et ce sont ces défis qui doivent
nous aider à formuler des oeufs
le premier veut c'est évidemment que la
santé du pays s'améliore qu'on arrive à
vaincre cette épidémie évidemment le
vaccin est un très grand espoir pour
beaucoup d'entre nous très grand espoir
qu'on puisse enfin réouvrir les
universités réouvrir un certain nombre
d'activités réouvrir l'activité des
théâtres l'activité du spectacle vivant
l'activité de la culture
tout cela est évidemment au coeur de
notre règles du vivre ensemble de nous
de notre manière de vivre ensemble
et puis ensuite il faut que nous
rebâtissions notre économie et si j'ose
dire que nous la rebâtissions plus
fortes qu'elles n'étaient auparavant pas
ce que la crise nous a permis de
découvrir beaucoup de faiblesses
beaucoup de manques et beaucoup de
risques qu'ils font que probablement la
france a devant elle des défis plus
important encore que tous les autres
pays européens nos partenaires qui nous
entoure et puis troisièmement il faut
que nous redécouvrons une règles du
vivre ensemble qui fasse que de nouveau
la confiance soit la loi et pas la
défiance est pas le doute est pas le
soupçon que nous puissions nous serrer
les coudes pour relever les défis et que
nous puissions simplement avoir le
sentiment que c'est mieux de vivre
ensemble que de vivre les uns contre les
autres
voilà les voeux que je voulais formulé
que l'on recouvre la sécurité la santé
que l'on puisse de nouveau reconquérir
des secteurs d'activité qui ont disparu
et que nous réapprenions à vivre
ensemble à ce conte 2021 sera une bonne
année en tout cas on n'en doute pas une
meilleure année que l'année 2020 qui se
clôt et à partir de laquelle nous
ouvrons la porte d'une année meilleure
bonne année à tous